I started by risking just $50 per trade
and over the next 10 trades I'll show
you that turned into over $21,000 in
profit. This was using the same simple
strategy executed the exact same way
over and over, just slowly scaling up
over time. In this video, I'm going to
show you how this progression works.
We'll start with one of the bigger
trades where I made over $4,000 so you
can see what this looks like at scale.
Then we're going to rewind all the way
back to the beginning, back to the $50
risk trades. So I can walk you through
every single one, what I saw, why I
entered, how I managed it, and how small
controlled risk compounded into
something much bigger. So, by the end of
this video, you will know exactly how to
execute this small account growth
strategy yourself. And the best part,
you don't need a massive account to do
this. I'm trading this using futures on
the platform called Ninja Trader. And
with micro contracts, you can control
risk down to a really small amount. Even
practice this on a demo account. This is
about starting small, proving you can be
consistent, and then sizing up when
you're ready. So, let's jump into a
quick overview of this strategy so you
can get a basic understanding, and then
we'll dive into how you can grow a small
account yourself. So, I found it way
easier over time to just look for key
areas of support and resistance in the
market and bet the the market is going
to reverse off of them. That's all I
trade. I don't trade continuation
patterns. This shift completely changed
my trading. I was able to instead of
being reactionary to the market, I
started to wait for the market to come
to where I want it, which made my
trading way more profitable. So, when it
gets to a key area that I think the
market could reverse, I just have a
simplest step checklist I use every time
to confirm to get in a trade or not.
Rinsing and repeating this every single
trade and day. So, the first thing I do
every morning is I open my charts and
look at a 15-minute chart of the S&P 500
futures and the NASDAQ futures. I look
for key swings in the market to draw
areas of support and resistance off of
those so when the market opens, I can
identify where they are. I have another
video that goes way more in depth into
drawing these key support and resistance
levels. If you want to check that out,
you can look for it right here. And then
once I've identified those levels, I go
into a one minute chart and look for a
few key steps when it hits that level to
see if it's going to reverse or not. And
then I'll take a trade in that reversal
direction. So here's an example of a
real trade I took where the market had
come down to this support zone. And so
what I look for is I go to a one minute
chart because I want to see what the
trend looks like into that level and
then read into the candlestick patterns
that happen. And so what I'm looking for
here is as I entered this trade is the
first biggest thing that I needed to see
is this downtrend be broken. I actually
had a trend line here. You can see that
that market has clearly broken that. And
the first thing and the most important
thing is that that happens because the
classic thing of the trend is your
friend still holds of is if this is
going to just continue lower, it's going
to continue lower no matter how good of
a support zone you're looking at. And so
I don't want to be paying attention or
jumping into a trade if it's just going
to continue lower. And so that's the
first signal for me that a trend is
going to potentially shift is that the
bigger picture trend is reversing. Step
two is that you have a big move down
into that level. So if we look at here
on a five-minute chart, you can see that
the market actually opened up here and
then it had three big candlesticks down
where it essentially ripped down lower
in about 15 minutes. It made a big move
very very fast. And so I call this an
unhealthy move. And because if that
happens and the market makes an
unhealthy move down, well, it's likely
to reverse that move very quickly, too.
And so this is what I call a catalyst
for a good trade to potentially happen.
And so if that aligns up as well, that's
another thing checked off my list of,
okay, this is a good potential spot to
take a trade. And so the next big key
step in this is looking for a
candlestick reversal pattern. And what
that is is down here you can see there's
a head and shoulders pattern.
Essentially what this is showing you is
that the market has made a bottoming
pattern where it's attempted to go
lower. It's bounced and it's continued
that trend. And then what this move
right here shows you is that it's now
reversing making a higher low and it's
starting to trend upwards. And so that's
what I like to see near this level after
a big move down and when that move down
was unhealthy. Now the last thing is
what I've discovered after a long time
trading is timing in the market. After
the market opens on my chart here it
opens up at 7:30. So 15 minutes after
the US stock market opens or 30 minutes
is when it can likely have timings of
reversals. And so you can see here on
this day, 15 minutes after the market
opened, had this flush and it reversed
pretty much dead on that timing. And so
these don't always happen, but again,
they're areas to look out for. And if
you combine everything together here, it
makes it way more likely for something
to happen. That's the whole idea of this
checklist is that you're stacking things
on top of each other that increase the
probability of a potential outcome. And
then the last thing to actually jump
into this trade. If I go back to the
start of this trade is how this head and
shoulders finishes forming. The idea
here I want to see is this high or low
in the head and shoulders pattern. I
enter in on a bullish looking
candlestick. If there's strength behind
it breaking this swing high here. If it
breaks this high with strength, I want
to get in on that. And so you can see
here it breaks that. I put in an order
and then it fills me and I jump in on a
trade here and then I move my stop loss
up below the low of this big candlestick
because I think that this big bullish
candlestick is a good enough
confirmation because as this candlestick
finished forming, it's a strong
candlestick. And so if the market gives
that back up, it's more likely to just
continue lower. And I just want to be
out at the trade. You know, I'm wrong.
Trade didn't work out. You know, this
isn't a 100% win rate strategy, right?
nothing is. But over time, the idea is
that I'm risking let's say one risk of
let's say like $100 and I go for three
times my risk a lot of the time. And so
that's the key important part of this
strategy. And then to manage it, what I
do is I like to let the thing move in my
favor a little bit because the market,
even if it moves up here, it could have
a pullback and I don't want to go break
even too early because it could just be
making higher highs and higher lows in
an uptrend and I would have closed out
early and missed the whole swing. And so
I like to see it move up to somewhere up
here like one one and a halfx. Really
depends on the market. And this is
something you'll get better over time
once you get better at understanding
these markets and trades and how they
move. But, you know, once it kind of
gets up there, you can see there I moved
my stop to break even because, well, if
it if it gives this whole swing back up,
there's that's a huge move and there's
no point in letting it come back down on
me even more and losing actual money on
the trade. But now, I don't lose any
money. But also, you know, I would
rather not let the market come all the
way back on me and, you know, lose. I'm
up already basically $3,000. And so
there's a definite skill that comes to
managing trades very fluidly and it
changes from market to market. And so
with this trade here, the market was
looking very, very healthy. My initial
thought was, okay, well, this is where
the market opened. We might come up here
and I drew a little zone here. We might
hit this zone and then sell off. And so
what I want to see is I want to see the
reaction to this zone. I want to give it
a little bit of wiggle room. I want to
allow it to have a little bit of a
pullback because I think maybe there's
this uptrend in play and if it comes
back pulls back and then continues
higher, amazing. You know, that's a
healthy move in the market and that's
totally understandable of it could
happen. And so holding through that
little bit of that pullback makes a lot
of sense. And so from there though, once
it kind of starts to break higher and
this pullback is more confirmed, I move
my stop up to here below essentially
this pullback here. Because what that
does is well, if the market decided if
the market decided to double top here
and sell off, well, I want to just get
out of the trade, you know, sure I I
haven't made as much money as I'd like,
but it's still some and I did capture
some of the swim. With these trades, you
don't know how far the market's going to
move. it could, you know, shoot up here
crazy. Sometimes that'll happen or it'll
just move a little bit like this and
then start to go sideways. And so
adjusting for every potential scenario
is very important when it comes to
trading. And so here, the thing just
kind of chops around for a little while
and then continues on that trend higher.
And so what I look for here is it starts
to have a very big move up here. And so
now we're getting up to more of what I
would consider to be a bigger resistance
zone. and it starts to pull back. And so
what I do here is you can see that I
move my stop loss up below the low that
this forming candlestick made because I
think if it pushes up here and pulls
back, this is almost an unhealthy move
of a candlestick. And so I think it's
likely to sell off. And so I it sells
off here. It closes me out at about
$4,600 and I move on with my day. And so
that is a really good win and what I'm
trying to consistently do every time.
And if you want a good reference guide
for this strategy, I've made a free PDF
that you can download via this QR code
or in the link in the description that
will walk you through every part of this
strategy and each step so you don't have
to create notes for yourself. Okay, so
now let's rewind the clocks and I want
to walk you through doing this on
smaller trades so you can know exactly
how to do this yourself and how it's
possible with a small account risking
$50 when you first start. And so what
I'm trading here is I'm trading the
micro NASDAQ. And so what this does is
it's basically a futures market that is
onetenth of the normal size. And so what
this does is it allows you to trade
futures that are normally really big
size with a small account and you can
get the leverage that that allows. I
don't want to go too much into how
futures work because it is a whole video
in itself, but I'll link above a video
that will go in depth into how futures
work. I have found them way more
powerful than anything else like stocks,
options, crypto, forex because they
allow you to trade really small accounts
and then the way the platforms and
brokerages are set up is really
favorable for you. So going into our
checklist, the NASDAQ here sold off
overnight. And so here at 7:30, that's
when the market opened during this time
zone I was trading and it kind of
chopped around. Now it it pushed higher,
breaking this downtrend, also showing
some strength. And so my inclination
with that is, okay, well, I see a
potential for this to reverse higher
because this downtrend is starting to
shift and break and it's showing me some
strength this morning. There is a bigger
picture support level here, too. It's
just not on this chart for some reason.
And then as well as that timing is right
here. If you think about halfway between
these is a five. So here is 7:45 minutes
after the market open. That reversal
timing is also coming into play. And so
what happens here is the market makes
this double bottom. At that reversal
timing, there's been a little bit of a
flush down here. It's not crazy big like
the last trade we were looking at, but
this is a nice confirmation of a double
bottom. A new swing high. The market's
essentially retesting this level and
then I'm looking for a bullish
candlestick to essentially reverse this
big candlestick. If we get a reversal of
this candlestick, that shows you that
this big candlestick was essentially a
fake out and that is a huge strong
signal for when the when the market
breaks above this that it's likely to
actually reverse higher. And so the
market makes a little bit of a pullback
here. I put in a buy stop above this
candlestick. I like to use buy stops
because I like to enter in on when the
market essentially confirms that
momentum is happening in the other
direction because the market could put
in a high here and then it could pull
back here and then keep going lower. And
so in that sense, it would be making a
pullback here and continuing the trend
lower. That's a confirmation that the
trend is continuing to the downside. And
so I actually don't want to get in
there. And so that's why I wouldn't like
getting in on a limit order down here.
But if the market comes here, pushes up
and then pulls back and then breaks
that, I think it's very likely that it's
going to continue higher. And so I get
in with two contracts there. I put my
stop down here. And you can see this
number is a lot smaller than the first
trade because I'm risking here about
$50. And so letting this play out is the
market kind of bounces around a little
bit and then it moves up further. And so
I it tests this high. That's where I
like to go to break even because I think
well if it's going to come up here it
could sell off. You know, thinking about
this day here is it's been pretty
rangebound this whole day so far. And so
in that case, well, I want to be aware
of that the market could actually just
stay rangebound for the day. And so I
want to close out at break even and not
lose any money if that's the case. And
so that's where coming into watching all
these different trades and realizing
every trade and every day is slightly
different. you're going to learn
something different. And so that's where
this moving that stop loss was very
important in case the market did that.
But that being the case, you know,
letting it play out, it moved up higher
and I wanted to see if it would, you
know, move up to this resistance zone.
That was my initial target. And trading
about $50, I'm up about, you know, 2 3x
here. And so just letting this play out,
I had a limit order right here at what I
thought was a good price to close out of
if it spiked up there. Essentially, that
would have been three times my risk. If
you think about my risk like this, I
don't have my drawing tool that I
normally use on this screen. And so the
market pulled back a little. There's
kind of this uptrend I'm looking at. And
I'm thinking, well, if it holds this
uptrend, I actually want to stay in. And
so realizing though that it looks like
it's going to actually reverse this and
close out, I moved all my stops up here
and close out of the trade fully for
about $250. And that was risking, you
know, about I think it was a little bit
more than $50 here. You know, maybe it
was 60 or 70, but you know, two three
times my risk was a really nice swing.
And so again, you know, as well, we
didn't really go over this is then I'll
just be done for the day. I'll be done
after that trade. 30 minutes. You know,
I'm literally watching the market for 30
minutes in the morning sometimes, which
is really, really awesome for having
this be, you know, a part-time thing
where you can go about your day, do
other things with your life. You know,
this can essentially be a easy,
manageable side hustle. And so, here's
another example that I'll quickly go
through. So, this is a big important
thing about this trade is you can see
right here, 6:30, which is an hour
before the market opens. this would
technically be 8:30 Eastern Standard
Time is there was a huge spike up here.
And so this is because market news came
out. And so this is super important to
do every morning as well. Just type in
Forex Factory calendar in Google and
it'll come right up. All this does is it
shows you the news that is happening
that day. It'll essentially have on
here, here's a a green arrow showing you
what's the next news. This is news
that's already happened before today or
the days before. And then this is news
that is coming up in the next days. And
so every morning I come in and I look at
this and I actually put on a filter. If
you go up here to the top left button, a
filter and I only have US selected
because I am only trading US markets and
those are what impact it the most. And
so what you want to do then is look at
okay and and this is set to Eastern
Standard Time. So the market opens up at
9:30. Let's say for tomorrow the
market's going to open at 9:30. So 9:45
minutes after that market open there's
going to be some news. And if you
highlight over this little yellow I
don't even know what this symbol means.
It's maybe like a little factory. I
guess that makes sense. is it says it's
low impact expected or an orange one is
medium impact and you know a red one is
high impact and so those you want to pay
attention to. Okay, at 9:45 we're going
to have minor news come in. Most of the
time that's not going to do much to the
market compared to something that is
high impact or medium impact. I would
highly recommend always watching those
because those are likely to have a big
impact. Or if you have multiple news
releases at the same time, that is even
more likely to have a bigger impact,
especially if they are red and orange at
the same time. And if you notice is the
9:45 and 10:00 a.m. That is my reversal
timings as well. That 15 minutes and 30
minutes after the market opens. So those
are huge times in the market to be
looking for news to reverse. Now this
one was pre-market. You can have those.
And generally what happens with
pre-market news is it will have a big
spike and then two things will happen.
Either it will hold and be really strong
and continue higher or it'll start to do
this and it will need to essentially
fill this move. It'll essentially have
to recover this whole move at some
point. Now that can take a while. You
can see here pre-market it was kind of
choppy and then the market opens here
sells off pushes higher comes up to this
high which is I would consider to be a
big resistance zone the market will
likely retest this level even if it's
going to sell off and so here you can
see it starts to I've got this uptrend
here super tight uptrend but the idea is
look at every one of these green
candlesticks is very bullish and so
that's broken when the market starts to
have a bearish candle candlestick here,
another bearish candlestick. It starts
to kind of go sideways. It's losing
steam when it's near this reversal area.
And so that coming into play, you know,
is giving me the idea of, okay, we have
a big push up here that was unhealthy
cuz there was no pullbacks in it. And so
that's likely to reverse. It's at a
reversal zone. Now, all I'm looking for
here is that final confirmation. And so
this is a big bearish candlestick. So, I
want to get short as it breaks this
because I think that well, it could
continue lower. Now, a little bit better
of an entry here actually would have
been waiting for this next candlestick
to essentially pull back some and then
entering in on a break. That's something
I've done a little bit better over time.
But that doesn't mean getting in short
on this big bearish candlestick is
wrong. This is just a little bit. You
can see here this is what can happen in
if you have a chop range and a big
candlestick forms. while the next
candlestick can reverse it as
essentially a trap. And so what I like
to do now is wait for this next
candlestick to form. And if it goes all
the way up and then reverses, I'll get
in short. And so here, you know, it
almost kind of got knocked me out and
then, you know, the big picture play.
That's why the big picture is most
important. Micro candlestick patterns
aren't as important because the big
picture generally will come into play at
most. So here, you know, I'm about up
one times my risk here. And, you know,
I'm up about $70. And so I'm risking
about $70 on this trade. And the market
then continues to move lower, has a
little bit of a pullback. I go to break
even because the idea with that is,
well, you know, maybe we're just in this
choppy range. You know, here is a minor
support level where the market's bounced
twice, three times. Maybe it's just
going to come down here, test this, and
and move back up. And so that's where
again reading the market pattern that
specific day is so extremely important
to how you approach trading. And that's
where being flexible to what the market
is doing is extremely important. But you
can see here it played out in my favor.
Moved down. I started to see, okay,
there's a downtrend here. I'm going to
actually move my stop down some to
capture some potential profits if it
pulls back on me. And then, you know,
it's just waiting to see if it continues
lower. And then it makes this pullback
here. breaks this low and that's when I
move my stop below because that to me
that essentially confirms that this
swing lower is in play and it's a good
swing low to confirm. And so here it
starts to get like I was talking about
before is this move up is going to give
back all the way in. So in the sense
that's making me a target. I'm assuming
that the market's going to bounce
somewhere in this area. I'm expecting
this move to reverse. And so once that's
reversed, I want to get out of the
trade. If it continues lower in this
extreme fashion, great. But if it's
going to go down here and pull back, I
don't want to give it that much room
because it's likely to reverse off of
here. And so I want to capture as much
of that move and much of the profits as
possible. And if it's going to pull back
here, looking at these candlesticks at
bottoms here, if it's going to come down
here and then break this high, I just
want to get out. you know, even if it
hasn't necessarily broken this
downtrend, it's close enough to the
zone. I like if it's going to keep
continue lower, I think it's likely to
keep continuing lower. And so I actually
get out here, I believe, on essentially
it pulling back. And so make about $200
on risking again about $60, $70. You
could trade smaller. The NASDAQ is a
little harder to go even smaller size,
but on the S&P 500 futures, you can
actually risk even smaller. And so here
is another example. And I have actually
upped my size here. And so this is again
showing you that you can slowly scale up
and increase your trading size. And so
here I'm risking about $150 on this
trade now. And this will help you see as
we scale in these trades. All I'm doing,
again, these look the exact same, but
the beauty of trading is scaling the
size. And instead of making $100 from
this move, it turns into $300. And so,
same thing, just to quickly walk through
it, because I know it's going to get
repetitive, but that's how trading is.
Is there a big spike lower, we're still
on the 7:30 market open time frame. The
market sold off, and now we're looking
at that 30 minute reversal timing. So,
the last two reversing around 15 minutes
after the market open. This is where the
market's pushing that 30 minutes. Now,
the market hasn't reversed here. And so
it's still, you know, it hasn't broken
this downtrend. And so this is where as
you're trading, you want to be looking
at the market and anticipating, okay, if
I look for a long here, what does that
look like? What am I wanting to see to
confirm jumping in on a trade here?
Well, you know, right now it's at a
zone. What could happen is just because
it's broken through here doesn't mean
it's not going to reverse. What I call
this is a failed breakout. It breaks out
of an extreme low, but then it fails to
continue lower and actually reverses
back up. So, it's okay to break the low
of the resistance or support zone. And
then there's this downtrend still
happening. And it doesn't again, it
doesn't have to happen exactly at that
reversal timing. Think of it as a good
rule of thumb and kind of a zone to be
thinking about. Just like these support
zones, I want to see it reverse in this
zone of time. And then from there, it's
waiting again for the market to break
the trend. And so here, actually, I do
something a little more aggressive
because I saw this as this big bearish
candlestick as a final attempt to go
lower and then the market got a little
sideways here. It made a low here and it
started to bottom. And so this is
essentially a micro head and shoulders.
You can see here's a shoulder, here's
another low, and then here's a higher
low. And so, you know, it's still making
this pattern, but on a very tiny scale.
But I like that because of how rapidly
this moved down into this area that I
was confident that it was more likely to
reverse. And so when it lost steam here,
I entered in, put my stop loss below
this kind of chop range because I
thought, hey, if it if it breaks up here
and ss all the way off, I think it's,
you know, the trend's likely to continue
lower. That totally happens. And then it
punches up right away. And so in that
case, I'm thinking, okay, this is I'm
I'm I've upgraded my size. And when you
size up, it's going to be a lot right
away. You're going to feel intensity.
You know, seeing this money on the
chart, I would suggest trying to hide
it. But seeing yourself being up a a
money way faster than you're normally
used to is going to cause you to want to
overmanage, like moving your stop-loss
up quickly or getting out on a limit
order quickly. And some of those things
are okay. You know, the idea here is
what I did was I said, "Okay, I'm up new
size. This is a lot. I'm going to scale
out two of my contracts right here. I'm
I have three contracts in the trade. And
so the idea is I'm going to scale out
out of 2/3 of the trade if it moves up
here in a very fast way. And so here it
essentially moved up, made another huge
candlestick. I actually moved this up
just in case it really spiked, but it
started to slow down and I closed out.
So I closed out $200 worth and then I
just had one contracts left. So I had
already captured $200. And so this is
how you can start to fluidly manage your
trades is, you know, I suggest trying to
go for just a two times f fixed
riskreward initially and having your
fixed stop-loss then maybe moving to,
you know, break even once it gets kind
of close. But, you know, you can see why
I do certain things. And then here, my
thought is, okay, well, I want to try I
still think that this has the potential
to reverse to the market open, which is
all the way up here. And so that's a big
move. And so I'm going to let, you know,
I I've already captured $200, I'm happy
with that. You know, if it comes all the
way down and knocks me out at break
even, so be it. But I'm going to let
this have a little bit more wiggle room
to see if it can get going here. Now,
you know, in this case, you know, I'm up
$200 now on this one contract. If I had,
you know, my other if I held on to my
other two, you know, you start thinking,
oh, I'd be up, you know, $700 or
something crazy, right? Which would be
huge size at that point. But, you know,
you got to remember, hey, it was a good
to take that off. And if I'm capturing
the rest of this, even with one
contract, I'm kind of doubling how much
I was up. And so, you know, it it spikes
up here. And I say, hey, you know,
that's a lot of the move already. I
would only be expecting it to come up
here a little bit more. I might have to
hold through a big pullback. I'm just
going to, you know, move my stop up
right below this candlestick that pulled
back because I'm okay holding through a
micro pullback, but I don't want this to
pull turn into a big pullback. And so I
think I believe it just, you know, pulls
back there, knocks me out at another
$250. And I think that trade made about
$460.
And so that's, you know, again, a good
two to three times my risk off of, you
know, again, scaling up. And so instead
of making what I was before, like $200,
now this made $4 $500. And so that's a
huge thing of remembering that you're
working towards scaling up. It's not
going to happen super fast, but when it
does, it'll be really, really rewarding
going through that process. Here's
another quick, super quick example
before we size up again. 7:30 market
opens, spikes up into that resistance
zone. We made a, you know, a pullback
here, and then a little pullback, and
then another high. So, I'm still
thinking, okay, I'm not jumping in yet.
But then it pulls back and makes a lower
high. Makes this nice bearish
candlestick. Again, thinking about the
candlesticks confirming your entry. So,
I enter in below the close of this
candlestick. And then, if you can guess
where my target would be for this is the
market open right here. Market opens
here at 7:30 my time, 9:30 Eastern
Standard Time. And so, you know, I'm
expecting to just give this move back
up. Even if, you know, the market has a
huge trend day where, you know, way
further down in the chart, it just
trends and sells off for, you know,
thousands of dollars. That's not what
you're looking to do here. You're
looking to just capture this move. And
if you capture that move and I'm risking
this, you know, I'm risking I think this
trade is actually still smaller size.
Actually, looking at this, I'm risking
about $100 here versus that last trade
was a little larger size. And down here
would be five or 6x. And so, you know, I
put in you see that you see I put in
down, you can see here there's a a box.
I put in this limit order. And this
happens really fast here is all of a
sudden news spikes this thing lower and
fills my limit order at that crazy
level. It happens so fast in seconds
that the trade closes. And so this is
why having limit orders can be useful
sometimes because actually if you look
at this that was 8:00 news. That was 30
minutes after the market opens news that
10:00 a.m. news Eastern time and the
news came out spiked lower. That's why I
put that limit order there because I
wanted it to come here and hey, if it,
you know, if it goes down here, so be
it, right? I don't know that's going to
happen. That's hindsight talking. But if
I get out in this area, I'm super happy
because that was, you know, if we go
back to try and look at the graphic
before it closes here, I think it goes
up to, you know, here's 345 and this is
still glitching lower. it moved so fast
and so it was a huge amount of profit on
that trade. But that's why having that
limit order there anticipating that
news, which is why you really need to be
looking at that and aware of that as
well, is really important. And in
hindsight, actually something I should
have done too is I should have moved
this trade to break even because in case
it spiked the wrong direction because
otherwise it could have spiked the wrong
direction and knocked me out at full
loss when you know that wasn't really
necessary to take that risk. But you
know I'm always improving as well. Now
let's switch it up a little bit.
Something I want to show you here is you
can trade this on other time frames or
markets. So, what I'm trading right here
is gold futures. Gold futures are super
popular recently because they are going
crazy recently. You can see this trade
was from months ago where gold was at
$3,000
an ounce. Now it's, you know, at four
$5,000. I don't even know by the time
you're watching this. Who knows where
the bubble goes, right? But so, also I'm
trading on a five minute chart. And so
what you can do is you can scale and
trade on a bigger picture time frame if
you want a slower type of strategy. I
like that more fast-paced one minute
chart focusing on the NASDAQ futures and
the ES futures because that 30 minute
timing in the morning has worked really
well for me. But I've also had times
where I've looked at, you know, here's
gold on a five-minute chart. And I'm
looking to you see a double bottom here.
There's a trend that's broken. There's a
major support zone here. It's just not
on this recording chart. And then I'm
just looking to see, okay, well, I think
the market's going to gold here is going
to reverse this move down and go higher.
And so these kind of trades take a lot
longer time just because it's on a
5-minute chart. And so you have to
realize that when you're trading, you
know, over this each candlestick here is
5 minutes. And so this is, you know, 45
minutes, an hour just to make this kind
of move. But another thing here is you
can see I'm a lot larger size now. I'm
risking about $500. Here's 1x and I'm up
probably about that same amount.
Visually, it looks like I'm about and so
I'm risking $500 here. And so this is on
the micro gold futures. And so you can
be trading this as well on smaller size
if you want to trade things other than
just the indexes. And so once this gets
going, just like always, move up to
break even because hey, if it pulls back
after making this nice move up all the
way down to here, just call it for the
day. You know, don't get married to a
specific trade. There's so many times
where I, you know, it looks amazing and
it's, you know, it's even on a big
picture, you know, it's, oh wow, I've
caught a huge bottom. there's so much
potential for it to go up to, you know,
$8,000 a coin or an ounce and, you know,
if I hold on to this, I'll just make a
crazy amount of money. The market
doesn't like to play by those rules. And
a lot of times, even if that theory is
right, trading to hold that is way more
complicated because it's more likely
that it's going to have a pullback at
some point in that and start to maybe
look weaker and, you know, have a bigger
pullback. you know, this is a nice move
up, but based on my theories of having
big moves ups that get reversed, well, I
could see a world where this comes up,
pulls back all the way down here, and
then continues higher. And I don't want
to hold through that whole swing. And so
instead, what I do here is I move my
stop up, and it knocks me out as it
starts to pull back. But again, because
I'm larger size, I'm okay with taking
this trade off here because it's still a
really nice win dollarwise. And so, you
have to keep that in mind as well when
you're scaling up with these trades.
Here's another example of taking a more
bigger picture, longer term timeframe
trading. And so, the market here opened
all the way at 7:30 all the way over
here. You can see based on the time
we're already past that. had a sell-off
and then I'm looking for this major
trend that it's had in the day to
reverse. And so it makes a bottom here,
makes a big swing up here, pulls back,
makes a higher low, and then I get in, I
put a stop order above this bullish
candlestick cuz I think, hey, I think
it's going to pull back here and push
higher. And so from there, I put my
stop. Always putting my stop below a
major swing. If it's a long or you know,
if it's a short, putting it below a
major swing high. And then from there, I
let the market play out. And so
essentially, if I go to this is easier
to see if I zoom to where there was a
five-minute chart pulled up is
five-minute chart. We had a sell-off, we
had a push higher, and then it basically
made just a bottom here. Made a higher
low. And so what I'm looking to see here
is this push to the higher side on a
five-minute chart. And this is of the
NASDAQ. And so again, this is how you
can trade on a fivem minute if you want
to trade something a little slower. And
so as it's broken this swing high, I
made a new swing high. I moved this
trade to break even because I think,
hey, if it pulls back again, I'm just
going to call it for the day. I would
rather see after this big bullish
candlestick. It pulls back some. Totally
understandable after a big bullish
candlestick. A lot of the times big
candlesticks get reversed to about 50%
of the their move and then it will
continue if it's going to continue in
that candlesticks direction. And so
that's what I was kind of waiting for.
It kind of bottomed a little bit and
then moved up and then I moved my stop
up a tiny bit with the idea that hey, it
made a little swing low here. I'll just
pull my stop up a little bit more. And
then I'm looking for you see my tool
here where I have my risk at $500. It's
actually a little bit more because this
is for six contracts. I'm actually at
seven. So up here is probably more like
$1,200, but it'll be basically two times
my risk. And so that's a good target for
half the trade. But because it didn't
quite get there, I actually moved my
stop up here. And so here I closed up
about four contracts as it pulled back
just cuz I thought, hey, it got to a
good spot. I'll close out some. And so
that closed off about $400, $500. And
then you see here I have still I have
three contracts left. And then it's kind
of seeing, okay, what is this pullback
going to do? Does it have more potential
or is it just going to kind of stall
and, you know, I'll just close out. And
so here, you know, I moved my stop up a
little bit more, but you can start to
see if you just look at the candlesticks
here, it's kind of just stalling out.
What I would want to see is, you know,
some follow through in these
candlesticks. And it's also broken this
trend line. So that's a good signal
that, okay, my stop's probably in a good
spot. and you know, I'll get out if it
just continues lower and I won't move
this. And so, this is a good situation
where closing those contracts out
further up actually got me a better
price than waiting. And so, even here,
if you were just going for a strict
limit of 2x, sometimes that is actually
more profitable than having a more fluid
style like I do here. And so there's
nothing wrong with you could always just
do a strict two times your risk and just
be done with the day. If you want to
just keep your trading simple, there is
nothing wrong with that. That'll make it
so you don't have to think about all
this stuff while you're managing it. You
just focus on the entry, which is
honestly 90% of trading anyway. And
then, you know, it either works out in
your favor or it doesn't. And you know,
I would suggest at least moving up to
break even once like it goes to one and
a half times in your favor just to you
know, be a little safer there. And
again, the remember the idea of these
trades going back to more of a one
minute chart example of kind of my bread
and butter and what I highly suggest you
focus on is, you know, looking for just
these timing windows of here's 8:00. The
market pretty much put a top in here.
It's broken this uptrend. It's at a
resistance level and then we start to
top here. So, this one's a little
funkier than some of the other ones. And
so, I want you to look at that is here.
It made a big bearish candlestick, but
then I didn't jump in based on a break
of that initially. I waited for to see
how the candlesticks after reacted and
then I got in on a break of that low.
And that's what I like as my more newer
signal because a lot of the time is
okay, this is a big swing down. If it
pulls back and breaks that swing down,
that's strong because sometimes this
will be a bottom. Like here, here's a
big bearish candlestick, but it didn't
actually break the low of that. Same
thing here, bearish candlestick, you
know, broke it by one tick, but it
didn't really continue lower. And so, a
lot of the times in these uptrends, what
you'll have is over here is a great
example. There's a big pullback and then
the next candle just reverses it. Here's
a big candlestick. It's kind of hard to
see. Maybe I'll zoom forwards in the
trade. it'll show a little better is you
know big candlestick here big bearish
one pulling back and then it just the
next candle just completely reverses it
even here big bearish candlestick broke
a little bit but then the next you know
kind of move up completely reverses it
and so what I like to see is you know
this is a little bit smaller of an
example but the price movement from here
to here is pretty good and instead of
you know coming down here bottoming and
then just ripping back higher like it
was doing before is you can see it's
changing is the market came down here,
pulled up and actually had two kind of
choppy candlesticks without much
strength to them. And so in that case, I
think, well, if it breaks here, well, I
think that actually a good signal to go
down. And as well, in that case, I think
that helps confirm this lower high and
then, you know, betting that the
market's going to go down. And as well,
as always, with my target of going back
to basically the market open as a a
great initial target. Now, you know,
there's kind of some chop here. And so
it's not like some of the examples we've
had where it's just a clean move up.
This could cause some issues on the way
down. And so you want to be aware of
that is that there's not as much of a
void of price movement in this area.
There's a lot of back and forth which
generates more stability in that area
and so it makes it more likely for it to
come down here and have issues. But, you
know, since my stop's up here, I'm going
to probably move break even once we kind
of get down to here somewhere. And, you
know, I have my buy limit here. If it
just kind of spikes down there, and I'll
move it and adjust it accordingly to how
the market's moving. And so, here, you
know, I'm up like almost $1,000, 2x.
And, you know, this is, if you go back
in the video and look at some of the
earlier examples, this is like the exact
same strategy, right? Just more
contracts. You can see here I'm trading
12 now of the micro NASDAQ. And so it
pulls back here. You know, I I didn't
want to give it too much wiggle room. It
looks like it's going to knock me out
here. And you know, I'm up about 1x,
$700, $600. So I wasn't up that,000
bucks, but again, always trying to be
fluid with the idea that, hey, I think
it could run into resistance down here.
And I don't want to give it too much
wiggle room. And you can see zooming
forwards a little bit there. Pretty good
spike there. And so all I was looking
for was holding this tight downtrend.
And then when that breaks, well, it
could shift and remove in the other
direction. That's what you want to be
thinking about with these trades is what
is the market likely to do if it breaks
this downtrend or this trend? You know,
what does that mean? Will it, you know,
what will be the recovery of this? It
could totally come back all the way up
to here and then maybe it moves down.
So, at that point, you know, I'm
basically back at break even. And so,
that's how I like to think about trades
of when I'm managing them. and assuming
what the market is going to do. Now,
here we're going to jump up to a larger
size trade example again where I'm
risking $1,500 on the trade. Now, I've
sized up again and you see triple is now
$4,500
on 3x win. And so, that is a lot of
money. And that's a long ways from
risking $50. And so, you can see the
power of I'm doing the exact same thing
here. the market. Now, this is a live
recording, so I apologize for the chart
moving around and stuff. This is a
recording of me trading it in real time
versus, you know, me just having a a
recording of it that I can easily zoom
through. But, so what you can see here
is I'm doing the exact same thing. The
market opened up here at 7:30 and then
at 7:45
it pretty much bottomed here and it I
got a support zone. It had a big these
big candlesticks here are a big flush
lower. And so I'm thinking, okay, that
has a good reason to reverse. And if I
zoom back here a little bit, what you
can see is there's a big downtrend here.
And so this spiking lower, I think, is
this trends. The market likes to do
final attempts to continue lower.
Essentially, think about it like a
bubble. you know, the market is trending
up. It's trending up and then when it
gets to the end of the bubble where it
just go it starts to go crazy where it
just goes parabolic and you know the
price like let's say of like Bitcoin you
know it goes from $1,000 to or to
$10,000 in like a week and then this
move from here to here took months. The
same thing is happening here on the flip
side is the market here was trending
lower and lower, lower and lower. It
took hours to do this and then all of a
sudden in minutes it moves this much
price where you know it took to move
that much price it took you know an hour
or 40 minutes you know way more amount
of time and because it's had this
downtrend where it kind of broke and
then does that that is a signal where
it's the trend is going to end a lot of
the time and so I see this as almost the
bubble is breaking in the reverse
direction. Now, this is, you know, it's
not a what you consider to be your
normal like big bubble, right? Where,
you know, Bitcoin will goes to 10,000,
100,000, and then sells off, right?
Those are big picture bubbles. These are
what I consider to be bubbles on a one
minute chart, right? They only happen
over like two hours, but the market and
price can still get overextended in an
unhealthy way to have to snap back. And
then these red lines I actually put on
my chart are those reversal timings I
look for for 15 minutes and 30 minutes
after the market open. So when it comes
down to this level and starts to chop
here a little bit, put in a big bullish
candlestick, I'm not entering in on this
thinking, okay, this is it, you know,
I'm going to catch a big move. I'm going
through my step entry checklist. I'm
being calm about it. I am waiting for
the market to set up how I want. Like if
you literally look at me right here, I
am literally just sitting watching this,
listening to music, patiently waiting,
seeing what the market's doing, and then
when it enters in or then when my signal
actually shows up, then I enter in on
the trading. So what I'm looking for
here is I'm seeing, okay, I like this
move. It's showing big bullish movement.
I want to see it pull back. I want to
see it make that higher low. I need to
see that trend confirmation. I need to
see where it makes a higher low, which
is to me the structure of the market
showing you that it's it's going to
actually reverse instead of me trying to
predict, well, okay, it's had a huge
move. I think, you know, we're at a
support level. I think this is where
it's going to reverse. That's not what
you want to do with trading. You want to
have the market show you that it's
starting to reverse. And so here I'm
looking to see, okay, is it going to
just bounce up here and move down or I
put in a buy stop up here actually
because if it breaks this high, I want
to jump in because that to me confirms
that it made a a higher low and then
this swing also got taken out after it
made a pretty good pullback in a
fast-paced moving market. And so here it
takes a minute to fill, but then I, you
know, jump in the trade and I put my
stop below this swing because I think
that's a good spot. You know, that's
where that higher low was confirmed. And
then from there, you know, I'm looking
at five minute. Okay, we have a big
potential to make a big move up here.
But also, you know, I'm going to look
at, okay, well, the initial target might
just be the market open or giving back
this small move here. And so coming into
it, that's where, you know, you want to
look at the big picture, but you also
want to look at the small picture of
what's likely, you know, where are those
essentially those tiers of levels of
where I would either, you know, think
the market's going to slow down or if it
breaks that, where could it continue
going? So that's where you can either
scale out or I like to try and hold on
to where it starts to actually hit one
of those levels and slow down enough
that I think it's going to reverse. But
other people, you know, that like to
say, okay, well, it hits here, I'll
close out, you know, half of my trade
and then here another half and then here
I'll close out the rest. And so again,
this is just where the beauty of size
comes into play. You can see I've
entered in here and one candlestick. I'm
now up $1,500 on a one minute chart. And
so dealing with this is hard. It's a
it's mentally strenuous having that much
money change in minutes. And so what you
have to do is scale up slowly. This is
why you start at that small amount. You
actually start demo trading first and
then switching to real money and slowly
scaling up because that's going to
really help you. So when you know you're
essentially building the foundation and
the building blocks of mentally dealing
with taking trades like this that are a
lot of freaking money and being able to
not freak out and say, you know, I'm
going to leave my stop down here and I'm
going to have a mental stop and I'm
going to be able to do that consistently
and not, you know, do make some
impulsive move and go with the reads of
what the market's doing. you know, only
wait until it gets up here. Hold until
it breaks this uptrend, you know,
because if you just sit here and watch
the swings of this money, it's up and
down 100 $1,000 insanely fast. And, you
know, if if you read into this, oh, this
is a huge spike. This is where I think
it's going to reverse. It's very easy to
do that, you know, down here and leave
all this money on the table. And so,
that's why you have to spend a lot of
time slowly scaling over time. And if
you haven't got it yet, this platform
I'm using here is called Ninja Trader. I
have used it for over five years. It's
super powerful for, as you have seen
throughout this video, managing trades,
entering trades really fluidly. You can
get thirdparty add-ons like this one
where it it helps me target how much I'm
trying to risk. And then also, you know,
shows me targets of, okay, four four
times my risk, I'm up 6,000. Three times
I'm up 45. And so they help you a lot
with trying to trade and manage. And
then these, you know, these tradable
buttons on the screen are built into the
platform. And so there I highly
recommend getting it if you want to
trade futures. I'll leave a link for it
in the description below or you can scan
this QR code right here. And so getting
back to this trade is pretty much same
thing as always with my strategies as
I'm looking as we go up. You know, this
was the initial target, but we've broken
that. So I'm looking at, okay, what's
the next one? this resistance zone. I've
pulled back from, you know, further left
on the chart, looking at like a 5minute
or a 15-minute chart, kind of looking at
where the big swings are. And as well,
looking at this, we haven't really seen
this as much. This is such a rapidly
moving trend that just like this being a
rapidly moving trend, it could snap the
other direction very quickly. I got you
got to take that into consideration.
This is a big move up that could snap in
the other direction very quickly. And so
because of that, I want to be very
aggressive with my stop loss because I
don't want it to pull back on me this
much. That would be giving up, I don't
know, $2,000, $2,500. And the likelihood
of that happening is higher and higher
as it kind of does this. But these
trends can also last a long time. And so
I don't want to leave that money on the
table either. And so in this case, kind
of moved up. We had another big bullish
candlestick here and I have my stop
right below it because my thought is
well, okay, we've had big bullish
candlesticks here and the lows of those
haven't been broken this whole move up.
And so if it has a big bullish
candlestick here and that low gets
broken, that is a change of the trend
and a change of the momentum. And so
right there I closed out for about three
times my risk. Super happy with the
trade obviously at that new size. And
that is a a super big win under the
belt. And again, market opened up 7:30.
This is done before 8:00. You know, this
trade is 15 minutes and I can, you know,
go on with the rest of my day. And you
can go on the rest of your day as well
with this strategy. And so, this last
trade here has something really
interesting about the management and
actually entry that I'll talk about in a
second. So, here, same thing as always.
I've actually changed my timing on my
chart. 9:30 the market opens Eastern
Standard Time. We have a nice sell-off
and then in this window here I'm looking
for a potential bottom. And so you can
see here downtrend as usual drawn. You
can even see there's big big rip here.
And then just looking at the
candlesticks, it starts to just change.
It starts to slow down, goes sideways.
And so I'm not going to enter in here
because this is just a chop range. And
quite often when a chop range happens,
it can go longer than you think. And
there can be a lot of big candlesticks
in here that like I was saying before,
they go in one direction and then just
rip in the other direction. And so they
don't really give you a good signal.
They just give you potentially fakes and
traps in the market. And so here instead
I am looking for kind of a head and
shoulders pattern where the market
bottoms here, makes a higher low. And
with this one you can see here we have a
this is a huge bearish candlestick. This
is you know in the ES this is 10 points
basically that is a huge candlestick and
even compared to you know this is a big
swing in the day normally but it's a big
candlestick even in relation to these
ones. And so what that can tell you a
lot of time is okay that's a lot of
momentum in that direction. Is it going
to continue lower? And if it does, well,
I think that this trend is going to
continue lower and I just won't take a
trade, right? I'll stop trading, move on
to the next day, and see if the pattern
I want to see shows up. But if this
comes down here and starts to bottom and
move higher, well, I think that is a
really good signal of a trap to the
downside. It's attempted to go lower and
it tried really hard and it just gave up
and you know the sellers dried up and
buyers came in and bought the heck out
of it. And so that's where I say okay
that's a really nice con confirmation of
a higher low confirming this bottoming
pattern at the timing I like at a
support zone. all of these, you know, my
checklist is lining up and then I get in
long, you know, put my stop loss below
that swing cuz again, that's a great
spot structurally to say, hey, if it
breaks this, you know, it's either going
to go choppy sideways or it's going to
continue lower or even if it does
somehow bounce and then continue higher,
it just wasn't meant to be, right? And
so then I just kind of hold on, let the
trade do its thing. I think I'm risking
about $1,300 on this trade. And again,
I'm my initial target is the highs of
the opening swing. And so from here, you
know, that takes a while. And one thing
to think about and to talk about here is
this doesn't happen every day. You know,
these I'm showing you really good setups
where if you can wait for a setup to
look like this every time, your win rate
and profitability is going to be really,
really high. But these don't show up
very often. and they show up maybe once
a week, maybe twice a week, sometimes
zero times a week depending on, you
know, the market structure and, you
know, the mode the market's in, right?
But that's where the beauty of scaling
comes into play. If you know, I'm not
there yet, but you can take one of these
trades risking 10 times this. And so you
could be up $10,000, $20,000 in one
trade. That's going to be my future of
scaling this higher. And so if I take
one trade a week and I'm up 20k, I don't
care. you know, you don't need to be a
huge trap that I fell into when I was
initially trading was trying to capture,
you know, all these swings in the
market. I didn't make money doing that.
And instead of I realized over time is,
okay, I just need to wait for this
specific strategy to set up and then I'm
going to slowly scale over time. And now
I'm finally getting to reasonable size
where it be can, you know, even if I
take two of these trades a month, you
you know, I can still be making like
$10,000 a month. And so that's where
scaling and the long-term big picture of
trading comes into play. And so here's
an example of where the market slowly
scaled higher. And you can see I moved
to break even. And you know, I was given
a lot of wiggle room here because I
thought this trend versus compared to
that last trade where it just shot up in
an unhealthy way. This trend is very
healthy. We're having pullbacks. Big
pullback here, hard to hold through, but
then another pullback here. Another
pullback here. And so I'm thinking,
okay, I'm just going to let it pull back
on me and I'm just going to, you know,
because it's in this trend where it's
just slowly chugging higher. And so even
though, you know, a pullback like this
is scary, especially after it's broken
this uptrend, you got to look to the
left, right? The market generally
repeats what it does to the left. It had
a big candlestick here, pullback,
reversed, big candlestick, you know,
pullback here, reversed, big candlestick
here. I'll actually scroll forwards
because you can't really see that, but
big candlestick here, but it, you know,
gobbled that up. Every time it pulls
back, the buyers come in and gobble it
up. And so that's why I'm trying to hold
with the swings and I hold a pretty big
pullback here. I think my stop was here
before. Almost kind of knocked me out,
but then gets gobbled up and makes a new
high. And so I'm going to I'm going to
pull my stop up to there. Now, because
it's broken this uptrend and it's at a
resistance level, you got to think,
okay, even though I want to hold on to
this trade, again, remember, you can't
get married to this trade. And if you
look at here, this trade is hours. This
was a very long trade. Not every trade
happens forever or short amount of time.
You know, I entered in this trade at,
let's say, 10:30.
2 hours later, I'm still in the trade
and it's still just chugging along and
I'm still, you know, as I'm seeing here,
there's, okay, here's the next
resistance zone. If it breaks through
that, here's the next one. And so this
is where sometimes you can capture a
huge swing in the market and it can turn
into a lot of money. And so here it
started to, you know, made a big push
up, starts to flag out. I'm thinking,
okay, maybe I I would assume that this
is going to break higher. But if it
doesn't, I'm going to look to get out.
And so here it actually this happened
pretty quick, but it had a weird spike
out of nowhere right here. And so I
actually move my stop loss up to here
because I think, hey, that's a good
spot. If it breaks this low after that
pullback already, I think it's going to
continue lower because remember, every
time it has a pullback, it continues
higher. And so this pullback here, even
though it happened, even though it
happened in one candlestick, it should
continue higher off of that. And if it
doesn't, the structure of the market's
changing and I want to get out. And so
here it eventually knocks me out here at
about I think it's $3,500 down here but
you know great trade but it took you
know three hours I think for you know
two and a half three hours by the time
this actually happened. And so that's
where you know managing it depending on
how it h how it plays out can be really
important because if I just traded this
for half hour I would have been out at a
lot less money and left money on the
table here. And so don't forget to get
that free PDF guide that goes over this
strategy in the description below. And
if you want to dive more into the nuts
and bolts of futures, how I read the
charts more, and how you can trade them
to scale your small account, check out
this video right here. It's going to go
into every detail for you.